[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and the voice of the dodgers charlie
steiner joining us how much sleep do you
get last night
not a
lot well you know it was one of those
you take it home and you try to say all
right it's over now
then try to tell your brain that it's
over
and then knowing i'm gonna have to get
up at the crack of dawn to spend some
time with you today
uh good morning good morning
do you judge your own call
um
yay and nay you know
it was when you have a call like that
the first priority as you're going
through it is oh lord please don't screw
it up
and then when you get to a a concluding
point where all right now i can shut up
and lay out then i know i've done pretty
well aaron boone was
the first
one where it was like whoa
and i remember as he was circling the
bases
and and i concluded the call i clinched
my fist under the desk and said yeah
i think that has some legs
and and last night i suppose it was kind
of the same
um
again i have been so lucky to have had
the boon call now the taylor call
walk off
games
uh
ending in just high drama
and complete elation and you try to do
it try to do it right then lay out
but also
i don't know how you can handicap this
because it's not like you go this is a
guy who's going to hit a walk-off home
run
you have to be prepared for maybe it's a
you know base hitting the gap or
something but in your mind
do you have scenarios
no
okay no that's i think that's probably
the worst thing you can do i think you
you just have to be there in the moment
you know in the boon call
i got it back about
two seconds before the crack of the bat
and then the home run we were coming out
of a commercial break
first pitch 11th inning and
i went yammering on this one you didn't
again you don't know it was an
improbable beginning to the inning with
two out nobody on bellinger who hadn't
hit a lick all year walks that changes
dynamic so if anything if i'm thinking
that i'm really not what about an extra
bass hit bellinger can run this could
potentially be a lot of fun but instead
of this crackling line drive and again
you don't have any time to think it's
just
processed quickly
also when you're listening you know
players talk about they can tell when
something's going to be a home run but i
think it's probably even more essential
when you're calling a game of just what
you hear like the sound of the ball
leaving the bat
how
how much do you read into that knowing
that yes this is a home run or this
might be a home run
it's really an audio visual exercise uh
a the the crack of the bat there are a
lot of cracks of the bats that end up in
four six three double plays uh but also
then
the dreaded launch angle it was pretty
evident uh
at the moment of impact it was going and
the last thing in the world you want to
do in a moment like that where a call
like that is going to be around for a
long time is screw it up so you want to
you want to be on top of it but you
don't want to oversell it for fear of uh
oh the last thing in the world a
play-by-play guy once in a big moment is
an uh-oh
have you had an uh-oh
oh
you just did
i guess that's another one
because you know we were watching the
red sox with uh stanton hit the ball off
the green monster
and the camera made it look like oh my
god that's gone and it wasn't just the
yankees announcer john sterling but uh i
think espn probably yeah had had the
call as well
that everybody thought it was gone
stanton thought it was gone but
like the camera framed it in a way it
was like oh my god it's gonna go out of
the ballpark
that was an uh-oh moment for everybody
yeah and it's one of the things as a
play-by-play announcer you hope to god
doesn't happen to you
how do you explain how do you sum up
this dodger team the difference or you
know how formidable are they this year
as opposed to last year
um
they have actually gotten better down
the stretch they were certainly helped
by a very weak schedule down the stretch
they were able to fatten up
they did exceptionally well on bad teams
this year they feasted on cupcakes and
they got themselves nice and fat and
down the stretch they were fortified and
and again this this one game wild card
thing i think it's tremendous the espn
had its highest ratings for a baseball
game in a quarter century i don't know
what uh
turner's going to get from this but
these were two great games
every moment was compelling
and yes sometimes there may be a team
that wins more than the other that
happens to get into the wild card i
guess they can finagle the rules to some
degree
uh but this was just great theater this
was so great for baseball it was great
for the industry
that at the other end of all this is the
dodgers and giants it's great i had john
smoltz on yesterday and he said he
doesn't like the one game he said it's
not fair to the team that wins more
games it should be the team that doesn't
have as many wins has to beat that team
twice whereas the team with the most
wins only has to win once what do you
think of that i think that's fair but i
think let's sit back and and relish this
moment and these two games and see what
reaction is around the country i suspect
these sudden death games are so
compelling i mean last night there were
350 360 pitches thrown and each pitch
was more exciting than the next that
doesn't happen
in the best of three
series it doesn't happen best of seven
until the seventh game it doesn't happen
but last night pitch one to pitch 360 or
whatever it was
every moment was compelling so yes it
may be unfair to some teams i think the
bigger picture is it's good for the game
i i'm with you on that and that's what
this is this is an entertainment
business you're trying to attract
audiences you might say well that's not
fair to the dodgers you want to be fair
to your audience and say tune in
we got excitement
and even like the nfl the nfl if you
score a touchdown in sudden death then
it's over but if you kick a field goal
then i like it if
you know hey you had the whole game to
win now it comes down to this and you
score a touchdown you kick a field goal
then you win i like that aspect of it
and i do think that the only reason why
we're talking about it is because the
yankees and dodgers were in one game
playoffs
exactly and and again
there was such drama
and
dodger stadium i'm very lucky to have
announced there for 17 years it was
yankee stadium before that it was it is
so loud and so dramatic and so visual
and each moment each pitch
built to yet another
series of emotions until finally the
bubble would burst i don't know how many
mixed metaphors i just threw in there
but the the upshot of it was when it
ended it ended with such a resounding
exclamation point to a thrilling game
between two great teams so i i i love
smallsy uh
most of the time i agree with them but
in this case
i think i learned something over the
past 48 hours the way the yankees and
red sox finished up their season two
great competitors uh and the dodgers and
the cardinals who go back to playing one
another since the 1890s this was this
was just great hollywood theater
charlie great to talk to you again and
uh have fun this series coming up i'm
sure you will and uh great job last
night
thank you dad that's charlie steiner
play-by-play voice of the dodgers on am
570 la sports